deep in the sea off the coast of Florida
new life takes shape these are
artificial reefs cement outcroppings
that over time encourage marine growth
dawn Brawley markets artificial reefs to
cities along the u.s. Atlantic and Gulf
of Mexico coastline cities desperately
trying to improve their shorelines place
a lot of reefs anywhere from you know a
mile or so offshore to ten miles
offshore coral reefs are one of the most
diverse ecosystems on the planet but
people are damaging the reefs by
development and pollution studies show
that up to 70% of the world's coral
reefs may be destroyed by 2050 an
unusual request by his father-in-law who
was dying of cancer sparked an idea of
how dawn could do more to protect the
environment and Carlton came over for
dinner one night and he said you know
Don Jane I got a favor - when I passed
away I'm going to be cremated and I'd
like you to put my remains and those
artificial reefs - bill I'd rather spend
eternity down there with all that life
and excitement going on than filled with
a bunch old dead people and we kind of
chuckled and said okay we can do that
and so they did and now the artificial
reefs are the burial grounds for over
600 others the deceased cremated remains
are mixed in with cement and poured into
a mold now Don runs a new company
eternal reefs that creates memorial reef
balls in small medium and large working
with families and governmental agencies
eternal reefs determines where best to
deploy each memorial
they're loaded onto a barge where family
and friends often draw their own
PostScript to a loved one's life with
the fish and then the eye above it that
sort of kind of reminds me of like
grandpa seeing everything going on
around it
what does Bridgeport says read - - and
then it's out to sea I believe that we
are deploying ever entail true and Burke
Larry Herman believes this is a fitting
farewell to his wife of 20 years I'm
feeling elated Karen who's a swimmer and
a snorkeler and she'll be swimming and
snorkeling for the rest of eternity this
is really the first time I've been able
to say goodbye des
[Music]
with each new memorial reef a community
under the sea grows stronger